House of believes is a novel by mark C
danielowski published in the year 2000
to met a narrative and a story within a
story within a story that is focused
primarily on how we discuss and analyze
visual media for those of you who have
had House of leaves recommended to you
by someone passionate about it I'm sure
the conversation began something like
this this isn't like normal books it's
not like a normal book wow it's
different I can't help but feel like
House of leaves is the Pick Me book you
know it's it's the I'm not like other
books of books over the years House of
leaves has built up a really interesting
cult following and from what I can tell
claim for this book was generally
Universal upon his publication I want to
lay this all out because I want to
discuss what I think works and doesn't
work in this book before I get into why
I think it's so revered especially
online today but first a quick word from
our sponsor wraithmark the sword of
kaigen is a fantasy novel that's
exploded in the Indie fantasy space
fantastic book an sfbo winner and even
better wraithmarked has launched a
Kickstarter for a special edition of
this book this is a beautiful book with
high quality offset printing cloth
wrapped hardcover and foil stamped case
embossed dust jacket a custom full color
print and Sheet illustration by Felix
Ortiz a custom full color map silver
foiled page edges Custom Interior Design
This Kickstarter starter that started
this month November and has done
insanely well not only are you getting a
fantastic book and a in a beautiful
Edition but you're supporting a really
awesome Indie Publishing Company every
book also comes with a custom signed
silver foil bookmark as an example of
what wraithmark puts into their
published books there's just a beautiful
copy of one of their books and a
gorgeous leather-bound copy of a mark of
Kings I mean this is really like high
quality stuff that they produce but here
it is Kickstarter assorted don't miss
out on this while it's here please click
on the custom link below it'll take you
to the kickstarter all right back to the
video
the book consists of several layers so
at the top level we have us reading
house we leave at the next level we have
the editors who are kind of this
invisible force and then we have Johnny
truant he is a character who is
constantly intruding into the narrative
which I will get into later but at the
heart of it and what I think most people
Come Away with and what I think is the
best and most interesting part of this
is a story about a family that live in a
house that is creepy
it's a creepy it's a creepy house and
you all know what the back rooms is it's
it's like a creepypasta online endless
space that's like a labyrinth and
there's a monster existing and that's
basically the house at the center of
House of leaves recently I made a video
talking about why I think a little life
is so popular today in a way both books
are more interesting to read about than
read themselves for instance a little
life has this whole YouTube genre of
people crying while reading it House of
leaves have spawned so many online
interpretations rabbit holes I mean ever
since it's been published it has so many
forums and dedicated fan sites I'm not
going to deny House of leaves is an
interesting book I think this book is
offering many different things and
throwing everything at the wall people
can come away with satire with horror
with romance part of it I think it's
just a structurally playful book it's an
experiment many of the characters are
one-dimensional in this book I thought
that the female characters were
especially poorly written felt like it
was touching on a lot of different
topics on the surface but the center was
Hollow
the problem with really dense and
complex art and especially ironic and
post-modern art is that you can kind of
get away with doing things poorly by
saying well that's the point there's a
lot of blatant and overt sexism
Defenders of this book can say well
that's the point it's a comment on that
oh this book is becoming incredibly
boring and obnoxious and going into
tedious academic details well that's the
point it's supposed to frustrate you so
much of this book's flaws you can
support by saying well that's
intentional Johnny truan and zampano are
two of the most obnoxious narrators but
also the most obnoxious writers and
there is some tentious writing in this
book that is played I think to be like
the point it's like that one kid in like
your high school creative writing class
who only reads Bukowski and Jack Kerouac
trying to sound really edgy you're just
reading over and over and over again
really poorly written sex scenes that
are so objectifying of women in such a
gross sometimes violent way John truant
is so much of this book he's like this
anchor character once that point has
been made it's just like a joke that
overstays its welcome
a major reason why I think this book is
so popular today especially with young
people and people who are extremely
online is that it is mostly a visual
graphic work it's really not so much a
novel as it is an art piece a book like
this is kind of all-consuming and in a
way it kind of patterns how we process
and interact with the internet where
we're not just on one linear course
through our interests through what we're
engaging with we have multiple tabs open
we're reading about different stories
from different perspectives you know
where we go through a Twitter thread and
then watch a YouTube video about it
there's a bunch of different narratives
coalescing and I think that's what makes
this book interesting how it is kind of
like a major book dealing with the
internet a lot of it feels and I hate to
use this word but gimmicky only the most
dedicated people can actually get
through it which is again why I think
it's more interesting to read about this
book than to actually read it because
the actual process of reading it can be
intensely frustrating at the end of the
day it's about how much you're willing
to put into this book and how much you
want to get back and the problem was I
was putting my full effort into this
book at first until I realized that I'm
not getting anything in return the
author is clearly trying to write very
Vivid real characters but I feel like
they're just stock characters there's
nothing unique especially the female
character at the heart of it there
wasn't much there besides like a pretty
pretty creepy short story and there are
some creepy moments yeah why this works
fundamentally white people love this
book so much ultimately is because there
is a nice story at the heart there's a
good creepy story at the heart of it
that is engaging it's not engaging
enough for 700 pages but it is engaging
I don't think you can just get by with
the gimmicks I don't think you can just
get by with experimenting with the
structure and the style I think that
there has to be more for people to
returning to reading for people to be
engaging with reading it anyways let me
know what other books you think are
interesting to discuss or do a deep dive
off thank you again to the wraithmarked
and please go check out the kickstarter
the link is in the description yeah
thank you for watching have a good one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]